also mein wunsch zum bundesheer zu gehen
denn habe ich eigentlich schon relativ
jung geschlossen also elf oder zwölf war
da und er kommt von einem einem ort an
dem man vielleicht nicht das erstes
denken uns police denkt nämlich aus dem
heeresgeschichtlichen museum in wien
dort war ich und habe ein wirklich
extremes interesse für militärgeschichte
und militär theorie entwickelt habe mich
aber extrem interessiert insbesondere
für die napoleonischen kriege und diese
faszination mit dem militär als
historisches konstrukt und auch die
militär theorie das ganze was
dahintersteckt diese führungsebenen die
ganze tradition hat mich so fasziniert
dass ich beschlossen habe eines tages
zur bundeswehr zu gehen